yes joe biden has coveted we will talk
about that in a moment but joe biden
also has sort of bigger problems joe
biden's approval has again hit another
record low for the presidency
these are not good numbers and i will
defend
any day
that joe biden is the better choice than
donald trump and that joe biden has made
better decisions than donald trump but i
also can't lie to you and say that the
country is responding super positively
to joe biden his approval rating is
really low uh the average is now down to
37.4 that's an average of recent
approval polls for joe biden 57 percent
of americans now disapprove this is the
most disapproval and least approval of
joe biden
since he became president of the united
states compared to prior presidents you
have to go still all the way back to
truman in the 1940s to find a president
that on month uh i guess it's month 18
of his presidency had an approval this
low you compared to
even trump had a higher approval at this
point in time in his presidency barack
obama george w bush way way better than
biden at this point bill clinton george
h.w bush ronald reagan uh jimmy carter
gerald ford john f kennedy dwight d
eisenhower you indeed have to go
all the way back to harry truman
in uh what would have been 1946
to find a president with a lower
approval
18 months in than joe biden
and part of what is going on is the
feeling and it is not an altogether
incorrect feeling that not enough is
happening that there are not enough
accomplishments and we talked yesterday
on the bonus show about the new idea to
get something done on climate for joe
biden is to do some executive orders and
the executive orders are sort of like
okay
but
they're not great
and uh the good news for joe biden is
that if we continue to
believe this notion that it's the
economy stupid that what the public
uses as a proxy to whether the president
is doing a good job
is the economy
and every indication is that inflation
has peaked and that the july numbers
which will be out in in mid-august will
be
lower inflation gas prices have now been
declining for
uh something like uh a month or more let
me look at exactly when
the june 14th was the peak and it is now
july 22nd so so basically five plus
weeks gas prices have been declining and
quite precipitously so
if that continues to go in that
direction if the stock market steadies
as it has shown some signs of doing it's
likely that joe biden's approval will
improve but it is currently not good if
you looked at the betting markets who do
you think will win the presidential
nomination for the democrats in 2024 not
who do you plan to support who do you
not who do you like who do you think
will win
joe biden's chances in the betting
markets are again
declining
and gavin newsom is there in second
place right alongside kamala harris and
the margin right now let's put it a
different way
more people believe
that either
gavin newsom or kamala harris will be
the 2024 nominee than the number that
believe it will be biden individually
biden still has a plurality but combined
people believe it will be newsom or
harris more than they believe it will be
joe biden so remains to be seen we're
watching that we're watching polling
we're watching accomplishments and of
course we're also tracking joe biden's
health uh as he does indeed have covered
with reportedly mild symptoms let's talk
about that next
if you're using traditional toilet paper
and paper towels you're probably cutting
down trees from north american old
growth forest and i've talked about
before we don't want to be doing that
also they come wrapped in single-use
plastic that's also a mess and the
solution is real paper this is a sponsor
i feel great about real paper makes
paper towels and toilet paper from fast
growing bamboo not from virgin tree
fibers from forests using bamboo
prevents soil erosion it prevents
habitat loss and importantly it's a
major impact on carbon real paper also
uses no plastic packaging so we often
talk about what can we do
corporations need to do many things but
what can we do to help the environment
this is an easy thing and i made the
switch to real paper at home i can't
tell the difference everybody buys
toilet paper everybody buys paper towels
this is one you can actually feel good
about and you can use the code pacman
for 30 off your first shipment when you
sign up for a subscription at real paper
dot com slash pacman the link is down
below